let me briefly followup about the
Melania Trump liking our video about her
story yesterday we did a story about how
on Twitter Melania Trump briefly liked a
post about our video questioning how she
got an Einstein visa last week we did a
story called how exactly did Melania
Trump get an Einstein visa and the story
a couple days ago was posted about by
David L rod on Twitter and the official
Melania Trump Twitter account verified
with nearly a million followers liked
that video which was weird by the next
morning that like had been undone so if
you went back to Melania Trump's Twitter
you would have seen that instead of
having three liked tweets she had only
one liked tweet and I speculated
yesterday it seems the most likely
explanation is that Melania or someone
using her verified account wanted to
watch the video and maybe accidentally
hit like or it's some kind of very very
nuanced trolling or something like that
this story has been picked up up to and
including by Newsweek Newsweek actually
wrote about the fact that First Lady
Melania liked an einstein visa tweet
with a video criticizing President Trump
that is our video and the article says
that I speculated yesterday that indeed
Melania Trump was watching the video and
accidentally hit the like button and
later someone decided to unlike it are
we ever going to know the truth about
what happened here my bet is probably
not but in the meantime I'll take the
media coverage of it right we've got
Newsweek The Daily Mail New York Daily
News The Mercury Observer and America
online at minimum writing about this and
it I guess what I go back to is the
frequency with which Twitter becomes a
sort of topic of discussion behavior on
Twitter is a topic of discussion for
many people in the Trump family is sort
of interesting who knew eight years ago
for example when President Obama was
entering his second year as president
that for the next president Twitter
would be just such a big deal
anybody else has thoughts about what it
is that happened here what it is that
explains Melania Trump liking a video
where we questioned how on earth she got
an Einstein visa let me know a lot of
discussion about it on our subreddit at
david pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program is sponsored in part by
brilliant if you watch our channel or
listen to the podcast yeah you're into
politics and you follow the daily news
and you want to be informed about the
world around you but maybe you also want
to dig a little deeper and on the
program we talk about climate change in
taxes and technology political
philosophy to really understand these
issues at a deeper fundamental level you
have to familiarize yourself with with
what's actually sort of underpinning all
of it and that's math and philosophy and
the hard sciences and social sciences
and that's where brilliant comes in it's
a truly unique and innovative online
learning service which lets you master
important real-world math and science
concepts this includes probability and
statistics logic and problem solving
renewable energy climate science
criminology you name it and you can get
started right ii by signing up for free
at brilliant org slash david pakman the
first 200 people who do that at
brilliant org slash david pakman will
also qualify for twenty percent off an
annual premium membership that is
brilliant org slash david pakman check
it out today